Ever thought about taking up a new sport, a new hobby, or maybe an instrument? If you're an adult, especially in middle age, learning new things is essential to keeping the brain fit. In this episode, we speak with a neuroscientist who is trying to not only prove the use it or lose it theory, but show us why keeping the body moving can also do our brains good. I'm Audrey Hamilton, and this is speaking of psychology. Tracy Shores is a distinguished professor in the Department of Psychology and Center for Collaborative Neuroscience, at Rutgers University. As a neuroscientist, she investigates how the brain learns and remembers.
有没有想过开始一项新运动、新爱好，或者学一门乐器？如果你是个成年人，特别是到了中年，学习新事物对保持大脑健康至关重要。在本期节目中，我们采访了一位神经科学家，她不仅试图证明“不用进则退”的理论，还要向我们展示为什么保持身体运动对我们的大脑也有好处。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这里是《心理学话语》。特雷西·肖尔斯是罗格斯大学心理学系和协作神经科学中心的杰出教授。作为一名神经科学家，她致力于研究大脑是如何学习和记忆的。
And when it comes to the brain, she's discovering how important it is to use it or lose it. Welcome, Dr. Shores. Thank you. It's a pleasure to speak with you today. Your research focuses on something called neurogenesis. I have no idea. Can you explain what that means?
说到大脑，她发现“不用进则退”的理念是多么重要。欢迎您，肖尔斯博士。谢谢。很高兴今天能与您对话。您的研究重点是一种叫做“神经发生”的东西。我不太明白，您能解释一下这意味着什么吗？
Yes. Neurgenesis is the production of new neurons in the brain. And of course, neurons are the major cells in the brain that are used to communicate. information. For many years, we didn't know that the brain continued to make new neurons after birth. However, about 10 or 15 years ago, it became clear that the brain does continue to produce these new neurons, and they're produced in a part of the brain known as the hippocampus. The hippocampus is involved in learning. So there's been a lot of work recently to show that
可以的。神经发生是指大脑中新神经元的产生。当然，神经元是大脑中用于传递信息的主要细胞。多年来，我们并不知道大脑在出生后还会继续产生新的神经元。然而，大约10或15年前，人们开始逐渐明确，大脑确实会继续产生这些新神经元，它们产生于大脑中被称为海马体的区域。海马体与学习有关。因此，最近有很多研究表明，
these cells are involved in learning and are certainly affected by learning. our brains fit seems to be a lot like exercising our bodies. Now you've found a way to combine mental and physical exercise. Can you talk about these exercises, also known as map training? What does map stand for? Sure. One of the things that's really interesting about these new neurons, not only that they exist in the first place, but they're also very responsive to conditions that people engage in in everyday life. So for example, the cells are produced. more cells are produced in response to aerobic exercise. So if this is a laboratory animal, a rat loves to run, and if it runs continuously,
这些细胞参与了学习过程，并且肯定会受到学习的影响。保持大脑健康似乎很像锻炼我们的身体。现在你已经找到了一种结合精神和身体锻炼的方法。你能谈谈这些也被称为MAP训练的练习吗？MAP代表什么？当然。关于这些新神经元，有一点非常有趣，不仅因为它们首先存在，还因为它们对人们在日常生活中参与的条件非常敏感。例如，这些细胞会产生。会有更多细胞产生以响应有氧运动。因此，如果是实验室动物，比如老鼠喜欢跑步，如果它一直在跑，
it produces many more cells than it would otherwise produce if it was sedentary. We also know though that many of these cells, once they're born, they die. So the cells are generated, but then between two and three weeks after they're born, most of them perish through a process called program cell death. So one of the things that my laboratory has been interested in has been investigating for nearly a decade now is the effect of learning on these new neurons. And basically what we find is that animals that are trained to learn something new keep the cells alive.
它产生的细胞要比它久坐不动时产生的多得多。不过，我们也知道，许多这样的细胞在诞生后不久就会死亡。也就是说，细胞生成了，但在它们出生两到三周后，大部分都会通过一种叫做细胞程序性死亡的过程消亡。因此，我的实验室近十年来一直感兴趣并研究的事情之一，就是学习对这些新神经元的影响。基本上我们发现，接受过学习新事物训练的动物能够让这些细胞存活下来。
If animals aren't trained to learn something new or if they're trained and they don't learn, the cells continue to die. So it really is an example of use it or lose it. So in the case of exercising your muscles, of course, you want to exercise your muscles to keep them to maintain their presence. In the same way with these new neurons, if you learn something new as long as it's challenging and you're successful at it, then the cells will survive.
如果动物没有接受学习新事物的训练，或者接受了训练但没有学会，细胞就会继续死亡。所以这真的是“不用进则退”的一个例子。因此，就锻炼肌肉而言，你当然希望锻炼肌肉来保持它们的存在。同样，对于这些新神经元来说，如果你学习了新东西，只要它具有挑战性并且你成功掌握了，细胞就会存活下来。
We've also determined that the cells, once they're rescued from death, they remain indefinitely. So basically they become so-called incorporated into the rest of your brain. And so I kind of wanted to take some of this information and develop it into an intervention that could potentially help people. And so we devised this intervention.
我们还确定，这些细胞一旦从死亡中被拯救出来，就会无限期地存留下去。基本上，它们会融入到你大脑的其他部分中。所以，我想利用这些信息开发一种有可能帮助人们的干预措施。于是，我们设计了这种干预方法。
It's called map training because it stands for mental and physical training. And we've been providing this intervention to several populations. Essentially what happens is our participants engage in 30 minutes of aerobic exercise, and the idea is that we're increasing the number of new neurons in their brain during this process. And then they engage in 30 minutes of focused attention, meditation.
它被称为MAP训练，因为它是“精神与身体训练”（Mental and Physical Training）的缩写。我们一直在向几个人群提供这种干预。基本上发生的情况是，我们的参与者进行30分钟的有氧运动，其理念是我们在此过程中增加他们大脑中新神经元的数量。然后他们进行30分钟的专注冥想。
So as you probably know, meditation is a very effortful learning process. And we use a type of meditation where the participant sits in silence, and counts their breath. One of the reasons many meditation practices use the breath is because it's always present, it's always changing, and it's always accessible. So the participant starts counting their breath, and then when thoughts interfere,
正如你可能知道的那样，冥想是一个非常费力的学习过程。我们使用的一种冥想方式是让参与者静坐并数自己的呼吸。许多冥想练习之所以使用呼吸，是因为它始终存在、不断变化且触手可及。因此，参与者开始数呼吸，然后当杂念介入时，
and they start thinking about the past or the present or worrying about some event, they are instructed to return back to the breath. So this is a skill. I don't know if you've ever done it you know it's pretty difficult to do to maintain your attention but you can get better with practice so we find in the several populations that we've done this that this combination of aerobic exercise and mental training through meditation enhances their overall physical health so for example the amount of oxygen that they consume
他们开始思考过去或现在，或者担心某些事件，这时他们被指示回到呼吸上来。所以这是一种技能。我不知道你有没有做过，你知道这很难做到并保持注意力，但通过练习你可以做得更好。我们在进行这项研究的几个人群中发现，这种有氧运动和通过冥想进行的心理训练的结合，增强了他们的整体身体健康。例如，他们消耗的氧气量
and their bodies increase significantly we also find that there levels of depression are significantly reduced. Their levels of anxiety are significantly reduced. And perhaps most importantly or most impressive is the change in rumination. Rumination is this process where someone repeats memories or goes over things from the past over and over. And women in particular are particularly inclined to ruminate about the past. And so one of the things that this intervention seems to do is lessen that tendency. And that makes people happier and more present in their lives. You just mentioned women and how they tend to ruminate more.
以及他们的身体机能都有显著增加。我们还发现他们的抑郁水平显著降低。他们的焦虑水平显著降低。或许最重要或最令人印象深刻的是反刍思维的改变。反刍思维是指一个人一遍又一遍地重复记忆或回想过去的事情的过程。尤其是女性，特别倾向于对过去的事情进行反刍。因此，这种干预措施似乎能起到的一点作用就是减少这种倾向。这让人类生活得更快乐、更活在当下。你刚才提到了女性以及她们如何倾向于更多地反刍。
What is your research shown regarding how women and men learn? Do they learn differently? They do learn differently. It's hard to make sweeping generalizations, partly because it's such a volatile subject, I would say. But there are some differences. Men tend to do better at spatial tasks. Women tend to do a little bit better in verbal-based tasks. In laboratory animals, we see fairly striking differences.
你的研究表明女性和男性的学习方式有什么不同？他们学习的方式不同吗？他们确实学习方式不同。很难做出笼统的概括，部分原因是因为这是一个多变的课题，我想这么说。但确实存在一些差异。男性在空间任务上往往表现得更好。女性在基于语言的任务上往往表现得稍好一些。在实验室动物中，我们看到了相当显著的差异。
And I have to say, the good news for females, as females, rodents at least, tend to learn better than males. On many tasks. And one of the nice things is that then they rescue more of these new neurons. Yeah. I think the important thing about sex differences is to realize though, that these are differences in the distribution. And so any individual, obviously, we can't predict how well they would learn just based on their gender.
我必须说，对雌性来说是个好消息，因为雌性——至少是啮齿动物——往往比雄性学得更好。在很多任务上。其中一个好处是，它们能够拯救更多这些新神经元。是的。我认为关于性别差异重要的一点是，我们要认识到这些是分布上的差异。因此，对于任何个体，显然我们不能仅仅根据他们的性别来预测他们能学得有多好。
Well, once we appreciate sex differences in learning or other cognitive processes, we can apply those to sex differences in mental illness, for example. So one of the things I've always been intrigued by and concerned about is the tendency for women to express symptoms of depression and PTSD and anxiety. And they do so much more than men typically do. And so some of these processes that we're learning about, these cognitive processes, like rumination, for example, might contribute to these sex differences. Can you give me an example of something you do to keep your brain fit?
嗯，一旦我们了解了学习或其他认知过程中的性别差异，我们就可以将其应用到心理疾病的性别差异中去。因此，我一直感兴趣并关注的事情之一，就是女性表现出抑郁、创伤后应激障碍和焦虑症状的倾向。她们往往比男性多得多。因此，我们正在了解的一些过程，比如这些认知过程，例如反刍思维，可能会导致这些性别差异。你能举个例子说说你为了保持大脑健康而做的事情吗？
Meditation, or do you do brain exercises? I'm just curious as to how you take what you learn in your lab. and bring it out into your real life. I mean, being a scientist, actually, is pretty challenging. I was going to say, that's one big brain exercise. It is a good exercise. And it's always changing, and you always have to learn new things, and it's always effortful.
是冥想，还是做大脑训练？我只是好奇你是如何将你在实验室学到的东西应用到现实生活中的。我的意思是，作为一个科学家，其实挺具有挑战性的。我正想说，那真是一个巨大的脑力锻炼。它确实是一个很好的锻炼。而且它总是在变化，你总是必须学习新事物，而且它总是需要付出努力。
It requires a great deal of effort. So I feel lucky to have had such an interesting career. I do like to exercise, in particular exercises, not just exercise alone, but I like exercises that engage your mind somehow with activities like sports. or dancing or something where you really have to think while you're exercising. I do meditate.
它需要付出大量的努力。所以我感到很幸运，能有这样一段有趣的职业生涯。我确实喜欢锻炼，特别是那些运动，不仅仅是单纯的锻炼，而是我喜欢那些能通过体育活动、舞蹈或其他真正需要在锻炼时动脑筋的活动让你的大脑参与进来的锻炼。我确实会冥想。
I only started meditating about seven or eight years ago. You know, I don't know if I could say I like it. I know it's useful and I find it interesting, but it's also difficult. I mention if you're doing it well, it takes a lot of effort. It does. And you have to kind of make yourself, at least I find, and I think a lot of people that meditate, they have to make themselves do it. Like I have to say, okay, now I'm going to meditate.
我大约在七八年前才开始冥想。你知道，我不知道我能不能说我喜欢它。我知道它很有用，我也觉得它很有趣，但它也很困难。我提到过，如果你做得好，这需要付出很大的努力。确实如此。而且你必须强迫自己，至少我发现是这样，我想很多冥想的人都必须强迫自己去做。比如我得说，好吧，现在我要冥想了。
I feel like I'm not very centered, or I feel like I'm really anxious, and you have to make yourself sit. I think the main thing that I wrestle with as an older adult, middle-aged to older adult, is finding new ways to really challenge yourself. I think as you get older, you tend to go back to doing activities that you already have done.
我觉得我不是很集中，或者我觉得我很焦虑，你必须强迫自己坐下来。我认为作为一名老年人（中年到老年人），我所挣扎的主要事情是寻找真正挑战自己的新方法。我认为随着年龄的增长，你往往会回到做你已经做过的活动中去，
maybe you travel to the same places or you do the same sports or you play the same music. And I think, you know, we need as we get older and as young people too, but particularly as we get older to really try to break out of our habits and challenge our mind with new activities, even though they might be frustrating. Well, great. Thank you so much for joining us, Dr. Shores. It was a pleasure. Thank you very much.
也许你去同样的地方旅行，或者做同样的运动，或者演奏同样的音乐。我认为，随着我们变老以及作为年轻人也是如此，但特别是随着我们变老，我们需要真正努力打破我们的习惯，用新的活动来挑战我们的大脑，尽管它们可能会让人感到沮丧。好的，太棒了。非常感谢您加入我们，肖尔斯博士。非常荣幸。非常感谢。
To listen to more episodes, please go to our website, speaking of psychology. With the American Psychological Association, speaking of psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
要收听更多节目，请访问我们的网站《心理学话语》。本节目由美国心理学协会制作，我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。该期节目尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。